he sees Britain as a valuable partner in
the European Union we've been partners
for more than 40 years and we would like
the United Kingdom to stay an active and
strong partner in the European Union yes
I understand that but as you know it's
Britain which is saying we've got to
have some kind of renegotiation do you
see that as being politically necessary
I think the message Angela Merkel sent
out today in Berlin was very clear we
want to build bridges we are ready to
listen to what the British have to say
we will have a closer look at the
concrete British proposals and we'll try
and find a solution Angela Merkel quoted
a famous German proverb today when she
said what an Villa is as a kind vague
where there's a will there will be a way
on the other hand one of the things that
some conservatives are talking about
including the Prime Minister on occasion
is this idea of changing treaties
changing the Treaty of Lisbon in
particular is it possible even if there
was a will to do that by the end of 2017
which is Mr Cameron's deadline first of
all we've got to wait and see what
actually the British government will
propose we need concrete proposals and
then we will be very careful at looking
how we can help what we can do first of
all we should look what can we do within
the existing treaties and if we have to
go beyond that treaty change isn't
always treaty change are we talking
about a minor treaty change are we
talking about technical amendments about
other possibilities or it or are we
talking about a major treaty change this
is a question which can only be answered
once once we actually know what the
British want because there is also
German concern as we saw in the meeting
after the meeting between Chancellor
Merkel and president Hollande a need for
greater integration within the eurozone
countries is that do you think a
hindrance to Britain or it could
actually be a help in as much as there
will be some members of the Union left
outside the zone not only in Brussels
but also in Berlin there's a will for a
fair deal for the United Kingdom a fair
deal for both sides we need a fair deal
which will have a closer look at the
pacific interests of the united kingdom
but
the other hand other member states also
have specific interests we will have to
accept that the United Kingdom will
probably never want to introduce the
Euro as a joint currency they will never
take part in the Schengen area but on
the other hand the United Kingdom will
have to accept that the 19 member states
of the euro zone want to integrate
further because we have to integrate
further to keep our joint currency
stable in the long run so I think a fair
deal a better deal for both sides but
should be the way to go once again
especially Germany is ready to help the
British where we can because there are
some countries France or elements in
France might be one of them who would
say well Britain has been troublesome
from the beginning General de Gaulle was
right
keep the Brits out of the European Union
the United Kingdom is member the
European Union since 1973 and the United
Kingdom has always been a bit different
than the other member states and the
United Kingdom isn't always an easy
partner however especially we Germans
see the British as very important
partners and friends your country is the
driving force when it comes to the
single market when it comes to free
trade we have a lot of common policy
areas when it comes to growth how to
make Europe more competitive and so on
and so on the United Kingdom has a very
good diplomatic service and you have
perfect armed forces so once again the
United Kingdom is such an important
valuable part of the European Union of
course the people in the United Kingdom
will decide at the referendum but from a
German point of view we can say we would
like you to stay we're better together
what about this question of migration
within the European Union I mean I think
it's fair to say that that is a problem
and has put pressure pressure on German
social services in a similar way as it
has in Britain I absolutely understand
the British concerns on this question in
general the single market applies for
all 28 member states and the single
market with the Four Freedoms including
the Fremen for freedom of movement of
people on the other hand I think there's
a lot of room to improve
natural national legislation this is
exactly the way the British government
wants to go and angular Merkel pointed
out today that Germany is interested in
finding a solution we'll have to see how
we can make this possible without
violating the fundamental principle of
the free movement of people I'm rather
optimistic that we can find a good
solution
what about mr. Cameron himself by
leaving the political group in the
European Parliament that your party
it belongs to he hasn't exactly said
about making friends in Germany or
indeed in the European Union has he the
Conservatives were a member of the
parliamentary group of the European
People's Party for many years in the
European Parliament they decided to
leave our political group in the
European Parliament a lot of people
including me were sad to see them go but
we had to respect their decision even
though we're not in the same political
group the British conservatives and the
German Christian Democrats have a lot in
common especially when it comes to the
economy when it comes to making Europe
more competitive when it comes to
fighting red tape and bureaucracy in
Brussels so once again we're political
partners even though we don't agree on
every single question when it comes to
the European Union we Germans especially
we German Christian Democrats see the
European Union as being more than just a
single market for us the European Union
is a political project but we do
understand that the British especially
the British conservatives take a
different view on this question but we
will once again find a solution I think
this was the main message of the day in
Berlin Germany is ready to build bridges
for the United Kingdom and we would like
the British to walk and cross these
bridges thank you very much indeed for
joining us from Hannover